Два тижні тому тут палили шини, зносили паркани.
Тепер усе вичистили, відремонтували, причепурили.
Нові Санжари за 14 діб, поки тривала обсервація
евакуйованих з Уханю українців та іноземців,
заспокоїлися. У день завершення карантину
деякі місцеві теж прийшли до санаторію. Багато хто
радіє, що люди в обсервації виявилися здоровими,
проте не всі переосмислили свою поведінку і хочуть,
щоб у Нові Санжари знову когось привезли.
- Якщо до вас ще раз привезуть людей?
- Та хай йдуть!
- Та да!
- Одного разу приїхали - хватить. Хай в інші міста везуть. Що, Україна мала?
- А мені хай лікуються.
А ні, а як ми захворіємо, то нас будуть гнати. Ось бачите, які!
Всю цю дискусію спостерігають батьки студентів-танцюристів,
яких вивезли з Китаю. Ольга та Сергій Павлови
з Кривого Рогу чекають на свою доньку і зізнаються,
що досі не можуть забути свої емоції, коли вдома
в прямому ефірі дивилися, що довелося пережити їхній доньці і її друзям.
- Як зустріли їх тут! Та ми були в шоці!
- Наші діти їхали в автобусі, а їм били вікна!
- В Китаї було безпечніше сидіти, ніж тут, на батьківщині!
- Одна жінка з вулиці кричала: Спалити їх!
- Головне, що наші сусіди не бояться захворіти на коронавірус!
Насправді упродовж усієї дії карантину
смішно не було нікому з близьких евакуйованих з Уханю.
Вони продовжують нервувати до останньої хвилини карантину.
105 українців і іноземців вийшли з карантину здоровими.
Багато хто - в ось таких футболках.
- Футболочки нам організували після закінчення обсервації,
тож можемо пишатися нашою країною.
Танцюрист Сергій Мейлехзон з Одеси так оцінює дії
медиків та інших служб, які опікувалися евакуйованими.
Протести в Нових Санжарах Сергій та його друзі по нещастю
пояснюють острахом непоінформованих людей,
які, зокрема, не подумали про те, що в ті дні,
можливо, не лише вони потребували обсервації.
- Обсервація була необхідна нам, але не тільки для нас.
Адже не тільки ми приїхали з Китаю.
- Тоді було страшно, але ми це все пережили.
Ми пробачили тих людей, тому що ми можемо їх зрозуміти.
- Ми були схвильовані, нам було дуже неприємно.
Сподіваємося, що більше це не повториться.
Привітати Нові Санжари і людей, що вийшли
з обсервації здоровими, прилетів на гелікоптері і президент.
Володимир Зеленський закликав українців обмежити свої мандрівки світом.
- Мені здається, що зараз той час, коли можна
займатися туризмом в Україні. Ви ж бачите:
у порівнянні з багатьма країнами Європи у нас
найменша кількість цих випадків, і ми це контролюємо.
Наразі в Україні зафіксований один підтверджений
випадок коронавірусу в чоловіка, який повернувся
з Італії до Чернівців. Перевіряють ще 10 людей
із підозрою на коронавірус. Урядовці запевняють,
що буде вжито необхідних протиепідеміологічних заходів.
- Найближчим часом ми, на жаль, будемо вимушені
проводити обмежувальні протиепідемічні заходи.
Ми будемо забороняти проведення масових заходів,
конференцій, спортивних заходів,
закривати тимчасово школи...,
буде розрив навчальних процесів, щоб зменшити масові скупчення людей.
Також не виключено, що буде обмежено або скасовано
авіасполучення з деякими країнами Європи.
Уряд вже колишнього прем’єра Гончарука
був налаштований на відродження санітарно-епідеміологічної служби,
яка була ліквідована кілька років тому.
В санаторії МВС в Нових Санжарах цю ініціативу підтримують.
Обсервація стала таким собі експериментальним майданчиком
задля відпрацювання дій усіх служб і виявлення слабких місць
подібних заходів. Отриманий досвід планують
поширити у всіх регіонах, де в кожному місті
мають бути напоготові щонайменше дві великі лікарні.
Як повідомили DW в МВС, евакуація з Уханю
та обсервація в Нових Санжарах обійшлася Україні
приблизно у 2 мільйони 600 тисяч гривень.
Ці кошти були виділені рішенням уряду.